so
as most people know game development is
hard right so there's always a challenge
um but it's us wanting to to give that
variety and
have
uh the ability for different people to
kind of make and tailor their ball time
in the way that they want to and that
makes it easier for us to understand
like okay we know that we need to
make sure that these four play well
together and that there's there's a lot
of that different variety so it was
really important that we have
some of our our past
type archetypes represented so that we
can represent and have that different
types of balance so we have omar the
siren she has some of the
similar abilities that we've seen in the
past from like maya
but we also have new things like she's
doing a face slam or she's doing like
the uh phase cast where she shoots
everything out and zayn um we see a
couple things similar to how some of the
past characters have acted but um
you know having the drone and the
digiclone where you can swap back and
forth it's really cool and really really
dynamic in the way that
you know if you just compare him to
amara herself and then like you talked
about moe's bose now has this huge
digitized iron mech that she can drop
down the iron bear she can drop down and
have
you can adjust the two hard points and
um there's actually
three different trees but you can
augment through you know up to six
hardpoints based on how you're leveling
up throughout the system so they all
play very differently so that even even
mindless will be very different from
your modes and we want to make sure that
people can build the kind of ball turner
that they want that caters to their play
style so you know borderlands at its
core has always been a
co-op experience that we really wanted
people to be able to engage and play
with their friends or play with people
online
you know we have couch co-op we still
have that in borderlands 3 because it's
always been important since day one in
the franchise
so there's there's a multitude of ways
that we that we're doing that in the new
entry um
if you saw the theater presentation you
got to see we all we're
allowing people to kind of send items
through the mail system
so if you find something really cool or
something that somebody that you know a
friend of yours might enjoy
you can send it to them
there's also
dynamic missions that we call the rare
spots the bounty board that you go to in
sanctuary three our hub and
our friend may have seen this type of
enemy in the game and now it will
populate an argument a dynamic mission
and we can now go and hunt
that's just kind of some of the way that
we're nudging people and showing them
hey there's a larger community out there
even if i'm playing solo i personally i
enjoy playing solo and there's a lot of
players who do
but we want to show like hey there's
other people out there you know like we
also got to look at the vending machine
right
in past those have always been just
populated by the system but now i could
go in my own solo game and see oh you
know one of my friends from my friends
there's an item in this vending machine
because they sold it in theirs so you
know we started off we wanted to make
this the best cooperative experience
possible even when you're playing
um
narrative has been not big in blue-based
games but borderline seems to take
initiative and take that step uh is
narrative a big part of worldwide
strength
yeah i think so uh we have a great
writing team our co-leads danny homan
and sam winkler and uh you know our
writing department has just been stellar
with trying to weave all of the
different more and the canon that is you
know the game is deep now
borderlands 1 came out back in 2009 and
there's a lot of pieces plus we also
have tales and things like that that
we're putting together there's all these
characters that the fans in the
community really love that we want to
make sure that we build on those things
so in this latest entry you know we have
the calypso toys we're chasing them
across the galaxy trying to keep them
from opening all of these vaults and
kind of getting this ultimate power
so that we can stop them from kind of
over running the galaxy with all of
their evil deeds and things like that so
uh yeah narrative and this one is
definitely important and we want to make
sure that that coincides in a very good
way with our new gameplay and the things
that fans have grown to love about the
series
marcus
um
so starting off um would there be any
interesting synergies and interactions
between uh specific port hunters during
the co-operative plane like we saw like
most uh chicken called on the eye and
the teammates can jump on the target so
are there any other interesting
synergies or injections
yeah there's a few more things that we
have with our sleeve on that uh what
you're referring to is the daca bear
augment that we have on those so what
she's allowed to do is she'll call him
the iron bear if you have that augment
it makes it to where and she can use
both of her hardpoints and her guns on
her neck but also a co-op partner can
jump on the top and have a chair that
they can use i think there's other ways
that that's happening as well like zane
being able to throw down his barrier the
augments on his barrier they can amplify
damage or they can give off you know a
health buff so that
if you're playing co-op you have
somebody next to you in the they're
gaining the benefit of what zane puts
down and then things that are that are
more obvious like amara's phase graphs
you know she grabs an enemy and now that
kind of focus fires and everybody can
target that as well so there's different
mechanics like that
[Music]
right so guns have been another staple
in borderlands uh borderlands franchise
uh they've gone from normal to crazy to
super crazy
uh you know right um yeah so moving on
to borderlands 3 there's gonna be an
exponentially larger number of guns
coming around this time around here the
designs
[Music]
so yeah uh how important was the design
process uh rather how important was the
design aspect for you guys in terms of
coming up with
the different types of plants um how
challenging was it for you guys
to come up with something that was
just digitally out of this world and
some of the designs that you come up
with
for the
initial designs i wanted to bring into
earlier games
then respect them
and decided to bring them into
[Music]
so that's always a thing that we think
about right like ideas are always
constantly coming a lot of that stuff
comes from the team comes from
us interacting with each other people
being like oh hey i have a really good
idea or oh what if
and you know a lot of our our guns start
in that that type of way a lot of things
that we do and we kind of you know get
in a room and huddle together and
bounce things back and forth with each
other and come up with some of these
crazy ideas like that
there's
certainly things that we've wanted to do
in the past or things that
we
are thinking about that we could do in
the future and
so a lot of that comes together whenever
we're actually in there building a game
right
the challenge with with making all of
the different guns is
you know finding the right touch to
actually mix with that gameplay and mix
it with those of all times like you said
there's there's different guns that do
different things we have guns that shoot
hamburgers
we have
the guns with legs that that bounces or
we have one that that's a tedious way
that sticks and it's a turret you know
there's all these different things but
all those go into the way that you're
playing the game too you can set up
those different combat pockets in in
that way knowing
how those guns interact
we have the atlas guns for the first
time in this in this game where you can
actually apply a tracker dart and now
your smart bullets you can go hide
around the corner and kind of shoot and
it'll tackle them so there's different
things like that and if you saw the
newest trailer we have a gun that shoots
guns
so i think that's kind of like the most
meta thing that we could have done you
know and there's just the team is really
great jimmy barnett and his team uh on
the art team
jetserrett and those guys who all work
with guns they they
have so much passion and dedication
to building on top of the foundation
that we've already laid down throughout
the series and we're always trying to
top ourselves you know
one of the things i like to say is that
you know we either get better or we get
worse you never stay the same so you
have to constantly be trying to get
better with everything that you do each
day and that's that kind of embodies the
team at gearboxing at frisco and quebec
we're trying to build on what we've done
before and kind of work together and you
know expand on these different types of
gameplay and characters and the guns
themselves
so that being said
does the think tank never run right yes
ah no no i don't think so there's all
kinds of white boards all over the place
that have random script it's funny
because we'll walk into a meeting
and see something just randomly written
on the on the dry board and uh
we just know somebody was in here
thinking of ideas about something that
has to mean something it's really random
but it has to mean something because
yeah we're always thinking about things
and we have our different channels where
we're kind of grouping together and oh
hey what we thought about this or hey
let's try and do this thing
you know we have so many people at the
studio and great ideas come from
everywhere we take it from you know from
the front desk support all the way up to
you know randy himself everyone has a
different ideas and different opinions
and they all matter to us
i think i just actually have like two
questions uh the first being you were
talking about
players being able to send gifts or
items to other players or friends that
they'll like if there would be any
chance them sending something to their
buddy that they've messed with since
high school that they may not appreciate
well hopefully there's nothing in the
game that people don't like right um but
yeah you can send whatever you know that
goes with uh grenades and um uh
different like shields and things like
that too so maybe if there is one that
has a has some type of a debuff on it or
some type of uh
uh
dynamic change that can happen if you if
you do a thing uh then you can kind of
stick it in there and maybe maybe it'll
get past and we'll be like oh yeah
there's a lot of help on this oh but it
explodes and hurts me whenever it
happens or something like that i don't
know how many
hours that we've talked about
it it's much bigger than borderlands 2
i'd say that
there's all different types of side
missions
there's the main mission of course but
then there's other things like all of
the different challenges that we have
like the rare spawns and the enemy hunts
and
the crew challenges things like that
like there's so much to do in the game i
can't express enough
all of the things that you're able to do
and that's just you know the different
mission type things that you prepare but
there's also exploration or you know
boss running and different things like
that so there's a ton of content on day
one
it's the same answer
we are in a streaming youtubing live
culture right so it's the balance of
hitting that and making it right
but also not being too over the top that
you know the people who we love the
people that they're based on
are kind of taken aback by that right
like we're not we're not making fun of
all streamers or all of youtubers we're
just saying there are some and the
influence that these guys have
they're taking it too far to the left
and making it to where they're they're
trying to take over the galaxy now and
they're actually trying to recruit and
broadcast and bring in and unite all the
bandit clans so that they can come
together for evil streaming deeds
uh my question will be
still the whole heartless we know that
all others each have their own unique
play style and strengths so does it mean
that some of the whole others will work
better in singapore while others i'm
also good quality cool people no i don't
think so um because now we have the
multiple action skills there's not
really a way to say well this one works
just in co-op or works much better in
co-op
even with things like you know i was
talking earlier about zane shield well
you can drop it down and it does have a
lot of benefits for co-op but also you
can pick his shield up and run and shoot
behind it so that works very well if
you're playing solo
but no we want to make sure that people
can play
literally any way that they want they
can make their bolt hunters the way that
they want they can
style them and customize them the way
that they want and they can play solo or
cooperatively and it still works
just as good there's a lot of things
that that we plan on doing with in-game
content and if you played any of the
borderlands then you you know kind of
have an idea where we're going but
there's not really anything that we want
to talk about today about in-game or
post-launch dlc or anything like that
because we're really focused on making
sure that we have the most polished
experience that we possibly can whenever
we launch on september 13th
um i don't know too much about the
accessibility
i know that we have ser several
different options several different
modes that the guys uh on the game field
team like we kind of we actually have
our own
department within the department that
kind of works on accessibility because
it's really important
but as far as newcomers coming into the
series
it's a first person shooter if you've
ever played a first person shooter game
then
then you'll feel right at home there's
the
recruitment
uh walk through that we did uh
with cloud at the beginning at the
game reveal event about a month ago um
we want to make sure you know in that
what you guys saw was that's kind of
stepping people through and showing them
hey here's the new things here's how um
here's how to play the game here's the
mission system here's how to follow the
map oh look we have sliding and manson
check that out here's how you can do
the aim switch you know in the aiming
modes
so it we want to make sure that even if
you if you've been here since 2009 or
you're playing the first time in 2019
then you can pick the game up and
understand that we're giving you
everything that you need to be
successful and you really enjoy the
experience
there's a there's a little bit of both
there's there's a few different things
now you know in the past you would use
iridium and buy things from crazy girl
that's not the only reason that
she we really wanted that tight game
plan and gun feel and combat right and
the team has worked really hard at
getting it to where things feel feel
really good whenever you're shooting
from the hip hand whenever you're aiming
down sight
but there's
you know i guess to go back to your
earlier question we wanted to make sure
that people who
are playing this game for the first time
it feels really good to them as well
um
and then things like progressing on the
characters you know we've added sliding
mantling and now buttstock is back in
this
or the you know so there's different
ways for you to attack
different combat pockets so
you don't have to just take enemies on
head-on you have destructible cover we
have
the different destructible burial
barrels that
kind of interact so there's so many
different ways for you to tackle a
combat space you can
run through and slide behind the cover
or you can mantel up on top and kick a
barrel over
and then those even those things
interact with other things like shock
barrels interact with water
fire barrels interact with oil
there's a lot of cover that is
destructible so
since our our enemies are a lot smarter
and our ai is really tight in this game
as well
even if those guys want to go and hide
behind it sometimes they might hide
behind wood and we can just shoot
through it and chop it up and still take
them out
you're
making it to where your gameplay is
directed and there's only one choice
right but that's not what we want to do
on borderlands 3 we want you to be able
to play
whoever you want however you want
whenever you want and doing it you know
the way that it was before it was
challenging and and so whenever we
tackled borderlands 3 we wanted to make
sure that
that wasn't an issue and that
with the addition of radiation
it's also a really cool element that
we've added to to kind of amplify that
gameplay so now you can hit enemies and
apply that damage over time but then
also if they're next to their buddies
and they end up dying because of it now
it explodes and now they're all infected
they can go pass it on somewhere else
it's extremely important that that's
that's kind of what we've been talking
about ever since we uh
announced and showed the things that the
gameplay reveal event and then now in
our theater presentation is that
there's so many different options and
it's because
you know not everyone has this one
kind of
archetype or this one feeling that they
want to do you know
even with with our ball tenders
my amara will be very different from
your will be very different from the
next person's life even in look and feel
and play style and that was really
important to us because
that opens up
the accessibility to that volume of
people there's more people that will
play and that will be able to play and
enjoy it because they feel oh i found a
thing that really
sticks with me and it resonates with me
and the way that i play games now
from guns to customization to the vault
hunters there's just so many different
ways for
you to be able to make that game
the way that you want to play it and be
your personal experience
uh
i would assume that she does
um and
i like to call her not so tiny team
but yes she's
she's in the game she's uh
she's always been a fan favorite you
know we love her and uh really excited
that she's more lands three
you